hello and welcome to this episode of the
apogee accelerator series
in this video we'll be demonstrating how
to implement a basic API consumption
limit using apogee's built-in quota
policy
apogee's quota policy allows you to
easily set API consumption limits for
client applications
imagine you'd like to set up a quota to
limit the number of calls to your API
over a given interval for example per
minute per hour or per day
you may want to only allow a set number
of API calls during that time period and
disallow anything over the limit you can
implement this using apogee's quota
policy
apogee allows you to set the quota to be
the same for all consumers or you can
set Dynamic quotas based on the API
product containing the proxy the
specific app that makes the request the
app developer or many other criteria
here we'll show how to enforce a dynamic
quota defined by the API product
we'll create two products with different
quotas to demonstrate how different
consumption tiers can be configured for
the same API
let's begin
in order to run this sample you'll need
the following an apogee X instance
provisioned with access configured for
external traffic
as a user you'll need permissions to
deploy API proxies create API products
and register developers and applications
this can be granted through the apogee
org admin role or the API and developer
admin roles
to deploy this sample you'll also need
the command line tools shown here
if you're using Google Cloud shell these
are already installed we've included a
Google Cloud shell tutorial which you
can simply click to quickly get started
now that you're in the cloud shell
environment you can follow along with
the step-by-step instructions
first make sure you're logged in with
the right account
then change to the directory for this
sample
to deploy the sample first open up the
env.sh file and set the configuration to
reference your apogee project
environment and the external hostname
next run the included script to deploy
the sample to your apogee instance this
might take a minute to complete
when the script completes you should see
a message showing the API proxy URL and
two API keys
the two API Keys represent two
applications subscribe to the two
different API products which each have
different quotas you'll use these keys
to test the quota Behavior
now run the code command with the first
API Keys several times
notice how the values in the output
update to reflect the quota counter on
each request
on the 11th call the response returns an
HTTP 429 status code which indicates the
quote has been exceeded the proxy also
returns a customized response body
containing more detail about the error
next try the requests using the second
API key this time notice the newer
larger value in the allowed field in the
response payload
this value reflects the larger quota
Allowed by the second API product
now you've seen the policy in action
let's look at how this is configured in
apogee
in a new tab open the apogee management
UI at apogee.google.com
under the API proxies section you should
see the basic quota proxy select the
proxy and go to the develop tab
you'll see several policies defined
first the verify API key policy checks
for the presence of a valid API key that
corresponds to a registered application
the quota policy is configured to check
against the quota limit an interval
defined in the API product used by the
caller the applicable API product
information is supplied by the verify
API key policy in a set of flow
variables
under the API products section you'll
see two different API product
definitions
the first is a trial product which has a
quota set to 10 requests per minute
the first application you tested is
subscribe to this product and you can
see that app listed at the bottom
the second product is a premium version
of the API which allows 1 000 requests
per hour the second application you
tested is subscribed to this product and
therefore it's allowed to make more
requests
this simple example shows how you can
easily allow different levels of
consumption for different sets of API
subscribers
when you're done with the sample you can
provide us with your feedback and then
you can use the cleanup script to delete
the configuration that was deployed to
your app.org
we hope you found this sample useful and
if you enjoyed the video please hit the
like button below you can also subscribe
to our channel to see more videos in the
apogee accelerator series if you have
questions please post them on the apogee
Community thanks for watching